I wonder if Krauss as a GM who has this
massive ego felt the only way I get any
credit is if I make some crazy trade for
Scotty the only way I get credit is if I
find a way to get Oakley out of here and
get these big pieces in the help Michael
win I need to keep making moves so I can
get my Pat's on the back because if I
just let this team play the team gets
all the credit
Phil gets all the credit and nobody
mentions Gerry crap I think he was also
thinking I need to win it without MJ or
I need a better player than MJ so people
see I'm the architect because for him
because apparently the soundbite if I
remember correctly was he who said Toni
Kukoc is the future of this franchise if
you say that in 1998 he didn't say that
but somebody said he said that fair
right if he said that in 1998 cool if
you say that in 1992 and Jordan is 29
and Pippen is what 27 the future is
right now this is the future is 8 years
from now when you're talking about we
got to pass the torch 7 years about
whatever it is yeah you guys just
repeated you are in the present he is
starting to be considered the greatest
ever pretty widely yeah there's no
future this is the future so this is a
guys can if you wanted this guy's gonna
come in really help the team he's gonna
fit in perfectly he's gonna help Scottie
and Mike they're gonna love having him
here that's if you say it like that
everybody's egos down everybody's guard
is down Kukoc did I mean Kraus did
koukos no favors with this is the guy yo
and this is me giving Kraus credit
because I'm playing devil's advocate you
know obviously but uh maybe Kraus on
some level knew how to motivate Jordan
maybe he's like the way you get the most
out of Jordan is you second-guess him
the way you get the most out of Jordan
is you create an enemy so I know Jordan
is gonna bust his ass to prove that he's
the Alpha of a team if I put my money
behind
Kukoc right and not my money my support
etc a guy like Pippen that might break
him emotionally right he might get angry
he might sit down et cetera but I got
like Jordan is like no i'ma show you who
the [ __ ] dude is yeah I would believe
that if he said it ever after put hard
and yeah that true maybe even because
there's a lot every years where he could
have been like listen I know I said a
lot she did Jordan I also know Jordan's
motivation and we saw would have been
skeptical but he never said it what did
that comes out into memoir could but I
just feel like if you're alive at some
point you would say it and he had to
know he's gonna die pretty quickly
because you gotta find ways to motivate
Jordan yeah have we talked about you
know you don't have to find ways Jordan
will motivate himself Jordan will always
find this light you'll find any but
create this light yeah they said that
Drexler is like me so now I have to beat
him the illest sound by was Danny Ainge
saying I knew it was over in that series
because they were comparing Jordan Mike
and and Jordans being deferential Jordan
Clyde yeah and Jordan was being very
deferential he was saying all the right
things and that's when I knew we were
done Jordan saying all the right things
is the most dangerous Jordan because you
know in his mind what's happening Danny
Ainge knew Jordan remember there were in
86 playoffs they were playing golf
together when his Celtics in bull so he
they're like friends yeah and so he was
like I knew I know this guy and the
second he's saying Clyde is a really
good player in his mind he said I'm
gonna [ __ ] kill this guy I cast
they're more dangerous Jordan than we're
not on the same level the alpha alpha
the Alpha alpha